m
bon maintenant t elle alors
rabat - le travail
mais si regardez moi inventer guillotin
ma fille est notée à huy ce montant
comme tout petit gars qui change à
offrir ses copains il ya voilà oui je me
regarde je bonjour bonjour bonjour c'est
une amie mais ce qui est arrivé mais je
viens de rentrer on a des outils bi ton
talent et comment colisée comme un nom
d'eddie va changer pas changé va changer
ce canton sont longues à augmenter ouais
c'est ça va mais on va garder en radio
mais non la mairie je n'ai pas de
comparaison à ce jour seul canton
voulons gâteau ou william hague
williams a lui aussi manqué les bons
gants je suis un faux d'armes et leurs
recettes et un petit peu mais pas trop
et alors moi je mange pas moi et moi je
mange quoi moi maintenant je mange quoi
maintenant je peux me dire ce qu'est ce
que je mange moi maintenant je mange
quoi là c'était bon je mange quoi
maintenant qu'est ce que je vais manger
là c'est fini c'est fini c'est fini
c'est fini
et
à
là
e
l'eau